Đói đồng bá lý được góp nơi hai mai thằng sau đã chính kiến những chân luận căng thẳng
liên quan tệ cuộc không kích của Mỹ nhằm vào các cơ sở hạp nhân của Yván.
Đại xuyên Rán Amil Saien Irabaní, Lên Ami và Iserang gấu tình phá hoạch đối thoại
đồng thời khẳng định cáu mô của Washington là Vô Cân cứ.
Đại xin Iserang ông, Jan Nhi Danon, ông Hộ, Chính Cuyên Cuyên Sự,
và tuyên bố viện năng trạm Li Rán sở ngủ phúc khi hạp nhân là Vấn Đề sống Còn.
Đại xin mi Ý Joru Tí Sia, bảo vệ lập trường của Washington,
chân rằng Iran không hợp tác và tý tụ phát triển trình hạp nhân bất chắc kênu lực ngoại sau.
Ngà và Trung Quốc kích liệt phản đối hình đồng của Mỹ.
Đại xin ngà và suy lý, Né Bình Xia, Cạnh báo về hộ phá lịch sử có thể là phải lại.
Chúng khi Trung Quốc nhấn mạnh phá cho của ngoại sau.
Tổng thức kỳ lý nước của An Trung Yêu Kỳ Rêx, phát biểu với hội đồng bóan rằng
một đánh bâm của Hà Kỳ Rêx, Lén Xóu, một bất hoặc nguy nghiệm Trung Quốc và kêu gọi hai bên trở lại bản đàn phán.
Một dự thảo nghệ quý giống ngày Trung Quốc và Pháp Quý Stang đồng bảo chờ,
kêu gọi nừng bắn nghe lập tất hiện đăng trụ thảo loạn.
Cũng trong phía nợ, ông Rạc Fèo Grosuy, tổng giống đất của quan năng lượng quyền tự của tỳ Yia.
Đại xin bay báo cáo xe bộ của bây thị thại sau của Khung Kết.
Cơ quan này đã phát hiện ra các hỗ bông gần cơn sử lâm sạo uraniyong phô đau.
Nhưng lượng ý rằng không ai kể cả Yia, có thể đánh giả chính sát kể thại giữa bất.
Yên yên theo Yia không có giấu hiểu dông gì phóng sản ngoài khu bực bác thật sự bị đánh bâm.